exactamente el objetivo principal de
este grupo será re unificar las familias
y entre las responsabilidades que tendrá
será identificar estos a cerca de 600
niños que fueron separados de sus padres
cuando llegaron a la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu el periodo de búsqueda
para encontrar estos niños es de enero
del 2017 y en enero del 2021 en este
periodo será en el que se buscarán estos
niños separados este periodo además
indica esta política del ex presidente
donald trump de cero tolerancia entre
las responsabilidades también están la
de prestar servicios de salud y de
servicios mentales la cerca de 5.500
familias que fueron separadas y también
considerar la posibilidad de unas pizzas
también para asistir a estas familias
el equipo de tarea tendrá 120 días para
entregar su reporte final al presidente
cristóbal en otro tema le pregunto que
dijo alejandro mayorkas el nuevo
secretario de seguridad nacional en su
primer comunicado público
claro y además ayer estuve en la casa
blanca- oficializando su nombramiento
como el primer latino y el primer
inmigrante en liderar la política
migratoria de estados unidos en el
departamento de seguridad nacional en un
comunicado dijo textualmente estados
unidos es una nación empática y crea la
bienvenida a los inmigrantes una que
encuentra fuerza en la diversidad yo me
comprometo dice mallorca a defender y ya
no sacrificar los valores
estadounidenses en la línea de pues esta
política migratoria que está avanzando
joe biden además también se confirmó a
wood y niek el primer homosexual
abiertamente declarado en estar en un
gabinete presidencial but dj estará
liderando todo el tema de transporte en
la casa blanca